thoroughly reflective views and opinions
of 8 news now or nextar Media Group 92
percent of our classrooms are
fully staffed with a certified teacher
so you know that's something that you
know it's not where I want where I want
it to be
tonight on politics now it's back to
class but short on staff we talk with
CCSD superintendent Dr Jesus Jara about
the upcoming school year
the number one thing I'm hearing from
parents is show me how it's actually
going to work the president of Nevada's
PTA weighs in on steps being taken to
make schools safer and Republican Senate
candidate Adam laxalt touts police
organization endorsements why those
groups say they're flipping sides
[Music]
from 8 news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now I'm John langler school is
back in session on Monday even as Clark
County School District gets back to
business there are issues it is still
working through short staffs low
graduation rates security this week our
Christian Casitas spoke with
superintendent Dr Jesus Jara
is the school district ready with the
number of teachers that we have because
we have a lot of vacancies also with the
bus driver situation last night we had
our bids for our bus drivers to come in
and bid for their routes
um then you know you're going to be the
first to know
um you know when we looked at our
vacancy you know we're down from 250
where we open to 84. right now today
right so our HR team still continues so
if you want to if you want to drive a
bus you know sign up and we'll get you
trained and ready to go so we're going
to be able to provide
um you know Athletics with
transportation that was a big issue
um you know last year right so our
transportation department is doing a
great job with our our HR team thanks to
the board who really looked at and and
working with our our partners in the
union to increase the salary scale for
our bus drivers so we're seeing some of
that 92 percent of our classrooms are
fully staffed with a certified teacher
so you know that's something that you
know it's not where I want where I
wanted to be we'll have adults but one
of the things that is different you know
people think about you know
teacher vacancy and and it's a it's a
national issue but it's not only in the
classroom it's not only in schools I
mean we know that this is a Workforce
issue across the country unfortunately
unlike the private sector I can't close
I can reroute I can't close and cancel
flights I have to take care of the kids
and that's what my principles and that's
what my staff and and the entire 42 000
employees in this community are going to
do what we need to do for our staff so
we are deploying every educator in the
central office onto our schools we are
deploying administrators who have
licenses onto our schools we want a
certified educator license in the
classroom with kids that is our priority
what is the game plan moving forward for
this new school year because there was a
lot of concerns from parents saying why
only one school a few schools why not
just across the board because this issue
really does impact all schools as a
father who sang kids to a public school
you know when you send your baby to a
classroom to be with their teacher you
want them home safe and sound to learn
that's the number one uh priority not
only for the child for the parents but
for us as well
um so you know we have a plan uh we're
executing on the plan
um you know that we have obviously all
the details are because of safety
measures you know we we are keeping
those close to our our best if you will
um but you know we're addressing the
single point of entry we are addressing
you know the fencing that we are seeing
um across in our schools uh we're
updating camera systems right to even
though that's not a uh I mean it's more
of a deterrent but it's really gives
that frame where we we can um we can use
to you know to catch the bad guys if you
will uh and and the instant alert you
know we're bringing to the board next
Thursday went through an rf3 process
where now every employee not just the
teachers it's support staff is custodian
every employee in the building we had a
great pilot of 10 schools this summer
but every employee will have an instant
alert if for not only safety but also
for medical emergency so you know and
it's aligned to our police dispatch so
we can respond
um as well there's been talks about
possibly bringing up the school district
your thoughts on that I mean it it makes
sense on certain angles but on the other
side it you know there's a lot of
challenges well I'm going to tell you
they've been talking about breaking up
the school district since 1977. I was in
Venezuela I was seven years old
you know my thoughts it's a good talking
point
as a superintendent you know when you
really think about it that's going to
take years to implement I got to worry
about the students that I have in
schools coming to school on Monday and
the Educators just to provide the
support and that's kind of where I stand
on this
you can see our full interview with Dr
Jara at right at 8newsnow.com
one thing that will be dealt with within
the next legislative session though is
school funding in the last session
lawmakers changed the school funding
plan and created a commission to decide
how much money was needed the commission
said Nevada needs 200 million dollars a
year until our schools are getting an
extra billion dollars Governor Steve
sisalak and his re-election opponent
Sheriff Joe Lombardo though have prom
promised no new taxes so it's unclear
where that money will come from up in
Carson City
how are parents dealing with the changes
as the school year is about to start I
spoke with Nevada PTA president Rebecca
Garcia about teacher shortages school
safety and improving achievement
expectations concerns just what are some
of the thoughts from parents heading
into the school year
well what I'm hearing from parents is
excitement to have another year back in
school
same time there are concerns because
we're already seeing that there's
long-term subs or no staff assigned to
classes as kids are getting their
schedule there's questions about bussing
and how kids are going to get to school
and so again it goes back to some of the
same issues we've seen year after year
but they're only worse unfortunately in
some cases especially when it comes to
like the Staffing shortage which is a
big concern for families if they don't
know who's going to be teaching their
child that gets very unnerving another
major issue with CCSD has to do with
safety uh recently they announced an
investment in some changes at El Dorado
High School Clark High School cameras on
buses there's some other things down the
pipeline is the district doing enough to
protect the the children from a parent's
standpoint the number one thing I'm
hearing from parents is show me how it's
actually going to work because a lot of
things sound good on paper but then when
it comes to putting it into practice
here in the Clark County School District
we see that it's inconsistent from
school to school maybe one school has it
one school doesn't one thing's in being
enforced here it's not being enforced
there and that's really what parents are
saying well it sounds good but really
what is it going to look like for my kid
in their classroom you know the district
is investing money in this what what
Solutions do you believe need to be done
district-wide
well the number one thing that really
keeps kids safe is making sure that
there's enough adults on campus and
that's one of the challenges that we're
not being able to see addressed right
now and it doesn't always have to be
teachers support staff positions whether
it's volunteers which are still a
challenge to get into campuses in many
cases in CCSD the more caring adults
that we have available on campuses the
better kids are supervised they have
adults to go to when they're
experiencing problems and can get help
and so yes these hardening of campuses
whether it's fences or cameras security
measures those that can be good as well
as additional policing can be a positive
thing but at the end of the day what we
really need is to make sure our campuses
are adequately staffed and have
volunteers and family engagement so that
parents are part of the solution and
that's where I think CCSD is lagging
behind right now local control that was
one of the best from a legislative
mandate from a couple of years ago the
State Board of Education is sort of
looking into this suggesting that the
CCSD is not following what it legally
has to do
from your point of view is CCSD doing
enough on that local control aspect
whether it's engaging with parents with
students and with funding
you know it's an interesting question
because so many people say they want
decisions made at the local level but
the number one complaint that I hear
from parents is the lack of consistency
and inequitable distribution of
decisions or resources in the Clark
County School District so there's got to
be a way to balance that where you can
make local decisions at the school level
but also ensure consistency in a
district where people move all the time
you can see our full interview with
Rebecca Garcia right now at 8newsnow.com
politics now who has the backing of
police the endorsement competition in
Nevada's Senate race plus a fight over
rent control heads to the courts the
debate over proposal from
foreign
welcome back to politics now
in North Las Vegas a ballot initiative
to control Rising rent is now headed to
the courts The Proposal came from The
Culinary Union City officials say though
it didn't collect enough signatures for
that initiative to go on the ballot in
November union leaders dispute that
dozens came to Wednesday's city council
meeting to support the proposal The
Culinary Union says rent control would
really help Working Families North Las
Vegas's attorney says quite simply they
didn't get enough signatures
whereas you not to support these
corporate landlords who benefit from
these exorbitant rents that is the long
and the short of it they simply did not
meet the required threshold so on that
idea of the threshold the main debate is
over which election should be used as a
threshold a guide for The Signature
Collection City and union leaders have a
different answer a court will make the
final determination
as Nevada's Senate race heats up both
candidates are touting endorsements from
separate police unions this week
Republican Adam laxalt announced several
groups that are backing his campaign now
that includes the metro police officers
Union the PPA the National Association
of police organizations as well both
groups endorse Senator Catherine Cortez
masto back in 2016. now they say she
hasn't come through this week laxalt
gave a brief speech saying she the
senator did not stand up for officers
during the George Floyd protests of
2020.
when those things came come down the
pipe everyone had a decision to make
they had a decision to go with that tide
or to stand up against it
from day one that tie that all law
enforcement in every single jurisdiction
in every county in the state of Nevada
and every state in America was
systemically racist and flawed needed to
be tore down and rebuilt
these law enforcement were accused of
that it was wrong
should point out laxalt did not take any
questions from the media at that event
meanwhile Senator Cortez masto has
gotten an endorsement from the former
head of the Nevada Association of Public
Safety officers and the union itself
Rick McCann he criticized black salt for
fundraising off claims the 2020 election
was stolen
on the one hand you were supporting this
lie this uh this idea that the 2020
election was stolen right you're
entitled to your opinion but that is the
Catalyst that caused death destruction
injury to law enforcement on January 6th
so you're going to support an event and
go out of your way to make that a major
part of your campaign that killed police
officers
at the same time you're saying you
support police
both laxalt and Senator Cortez masto
have served as Nevada's Attorney General
Nevada Democrats will have to wait a few
more months to see if they'll nominate a
presidential candidate first in 2024.
this week the Democratic National
Committee delayed a vote that was
supposed to take place earlier in the
week instead they will make a decision
after the midterms in November Party
leaders believe changing now would hurt
candidates that are currently running in
Iowa and New Hampshire those States
would lose their spots if Nevada goes
first Nevada was the third state to vote
back in 2020.
the Nevada Republican party is pushing
back on a former chairwoman who has now
endorsed a few Democrats Amy tarkanian
and former State Senate leader Michael
Roberson are part of a group of
Republicans that have endorsed Democrat
attorney general Aaron Ford he is
running against Republican Seagal Chatta
well those Republicans say she is too
extreme the state Republican party
defended Chatta though saying the group
of Republicans their political history
makes their names synonymous with
failure and makes these cries for
relevance all the more pathetic unquote
that from Michael McDonald
meanwhile the state democratic party has
hired the person that filmed himself
calling Republican gubernatorial
candidate Joe Lombardo names like Nazi
and garbage human being now we're not
going to show you that video but the
activist is Sean Navarro he says he is
the Coalition and Community engagement
coordinator
Governor Steve sisilak condemned the
video it's also important to note the
state democratic party is now run by
members of the democratic socialists of
America and a cutout called Nevada
Democratic victory in a separate
organization is running Governor
sisalak's re-election campaign
next on politics now is saving water and
business Senator Jackie Rosen presses
the park service to open boat ramps
closed on Lake Mead plus a deal on
Capitol Hill Democrats agree on a plan
to pass a scaled back version of the
president's build-back better
you're watching politics now
the Lake Mead is at record low levels
and shrinking now Nevada senator Jackie
Rosen wants to help businesses hurt by
those boat ramp closures five of six
boat ramps have been shut down at Lake
Mead because of low water levels and
that means longer wait times to launch
boats into the one ramp now at the lake
it's a real strain on businesses that
depend on tourism
the lake is going down and down and down
we have a lot of work to do on that but
it's impacting local tourism and it's
impacting those small businesses so all
that ecosystem people driving on their
way to the lake whether they stop for
ice gas groceries whatever they are and
people are doing business on and around
the lake so we need to press the
director to find Solutions
Senator Rosen wants the National Park
Service to share plans on reopening the
boat ramps and if not she wants clear
reasons on why they're still closed
States will have to come up with ways to
keep the Colorado River from shrinking
more a group of conservation non-profits
say part of the problem on the lake and
on the river is antique Plumbing at the
Glen Canyon Dam near Lake Powell
Christian cosidence reports
the system needs flexibility and it
needs flexibility now environmental
Advocates sounding the alarm on the
water supply crisis from the Colorado
River which impacts Lake Mead and
Southern Nevada residents the Bureau of
Reclamation
unveiled the call to Congress for the
seven Basin states to come up with a
plan within just 60 days to cut between
two and four million acre feet of water
from the Colorado River Basin Zachary
Frankel is the executive director for
the Utah Rivers Council he says the
water problem stems from old Plumbing at
the Glen Canyon Dam near Lake Powell
even though someone in Las Vegas might
not know anything or care much about
what's happening at Glen Canyon dams the
problem is that the antique Plumbing
inside Glen Kenya dam is has the
potential to prevent Las Vegas and
Nevada from getting its full water
supply out of the Colorado River but now
a coalition of several agencies is
recommending two possible solutions
either widening or drill additional
tubes to increase the water flow or
construct new bypass tunnels to rise the
river level once the water level starts
dropping another 45 feet we're going to
have major water supply delivery
problems to 30 million people it's
unclear how much the repair cost would
be but Frankel and the Coalition want
Congress to fund a study soon before
it's too late this really should have
happened five years ago Christian Casa
is live local now
so to recap there are two important Cuts
being announced soon one will be under
tier two restrictions for next year that
drops Nevada's allotment to 275 000 acre
feet that's the smallest amount of all
seven states on the river the good news
is we're on track to only use 242 000
acre feet this year however once the
cuts on top of those ones are announced
for that extra two to four million acre
feet our share could be lower than 242
thousand
after months of negotiations it appears
Democrats are closer to making President
Biden's legislative priorities a reality
a vote is expected in the Senate on a
scaled back version of his buildback
better plan here's Washington
correspondent Alexander Limon on what's
now called the inflation reduction Act
Democrats say they're on the brink of
passing groundbreaking legislation that
will make historic investments in green
energy but first they'll have to lock in
the support of Democratic senator
Kirsten Cinema we're going to invest 369
billion dollars
to address the climate crisis soon
Democrats hope to pass far-reaching
legislation containing some of President
Joe Biden's top legislative priorities
Senate Democrats are delivering on
historic climate change legislation
we're delivering on lower prices on
prescription drugs we're delivering on
tax fairness Republicans like Senator
John Thun are are highly critical of the
package I'm not really sure why the
federal government is going to be
spending money on electric garbage
trucks or how that's going to reduce
inflation but Democrats say fighting
climate change is worth the investment
this bill will cut our carbon emissions
by 40 percent those greenhouse gases
warmed the planet and make natural
disasters like droughts wildfires and
hurricanes worse the inflation reduction
act will help us avoid the cost in both
dollars and in lives the Congressional
budget office estimates the bill will
pay for itself and reduce the deficit
it's paid for by making wealthy
corporations pay more of their fair
share in taxes but Senator John cornyn
has a problem with how the legislation
is being presented the first thing is
it's misnamed it's not an inflation
reduction act it's a at best it stays
constant today President Joe Biden said
these investments will be passed on to
Americans for example by lowering their
energy bills and by creating high paying
jobs in Washington Alexandra Limon
and politics now is
live weekdays at nine
in what to watch how much water will
Nevada lose we're waiting to see how
much of our allotment from Lake Mead
will be lost when as much as 4 million
acre feet of cuts are made on the
Colorado River that could lead to extra
conservation measures being taken by the
Southern Nevada Water Authority we're
also waiting to see if that causes any
extra restrictions here in Las Vegas
plus we'll track the first day of school
Clark County School District starts on
Monday we want to see how safety
measures put in place are working we'll
have live coverage on Monday on 8 news
now and of course follow up all
throughout the long school year at Clark
County School District and all the
schools in southern Nevada
that'll do it for us here on politics
now don't forget for all the latest
political news head to 8newsnow.com and
we're back with you next Saturday as
well right here on politics now thank
you very much for watching take care
[Music]
foreign
[Music]